Let's face it,
A lot of people have changed their
routines in the last year,
they've had too.
People are staying at home,
they're not moving around as much,
they're not as active.
Well, guess what?
We have a sponsor that has a product
made just for these times.
[Narrator] Bars are still closed.
Concerts are canceled.
Dance clubs still haven't opened.
With no reason to stay up all night,
you don't need the stimulation
you get from energy drinks
like Red Bull, Rockstar and Monster.
That's why we introduced
Monster Low Energy Drink.
With no caffeine and fewer electrolytes,
Monster Low Energy drink
gives you just enough energy
to stay awake a little longer.
So you can play that video game,
do that minor household chore
and laugh at your bosses
joke during a Zoom call.
(laughing)
That's, that's funny, Dan.
[Narrator] Monster low energy drink.
(clock ticking)
What do you think, Andy?
Oh, I can feel my heart racing
to about its normal rate.
Yeah, mine is just now getting
to 60 beats per minute.
Yeah, it's thrilling.